[Music]
so what do you do in that box anyways
argue mostly
[Applause]
[Music]
hope you liked that line it's the best
one of the story so it is time once
again for me to take a look at a classic
episode of Doctor Who as selected by my
wonderful and lovely supporters over on
the patreon page link in the description
feel free to check it out now video will
still be here
this one was closed so I knew that I was
going to have them pick a Sixth Doctor
story cuts been a little while since I
did one and I gave them you know a
variety of options and you folks were
this close to getting revelation of the
Daleks said you get mark of a Ronnie
what can I tell you so this is the this
is the first time the Ronnie appear on
the show second time that I've
encountered her because I've already
done a review for time and the Rani
which hurt for many many reasons this is
[Music]
significantly less painful actually if
I'm being honest this is probably the
best Sixth Doctor story that I've done a
review on so far that's not to say that
it's great it would still be on the in
the bottom range of pretty much any
classic Doctor Who lists that I would do
based off the episodes that I've seen so
far but there's probably the least
offensively wrong with it compared to
other six doctor's stuff that I've seen
so far it's fine it's decent I'm still
gonna spend most of this probably
nitpicking and complaining because
that's what I do and I do that even with
stuff I like so yeah that that's gonna
be the case here so we've got this is a
six doctor story so we've got Colin
Baker and as much as I continue to gain
an appreciation for Colin Baker thanks
primarily to the Big Finish audio
adventures he's still not good in the
show's
he's great in the audios he's not good
on the shows and a big part of that is
just dick there's if you listen to Big
Finish there's a tweaking to his
abrasiveness he's still abrasive but
he's not as aggressively abrasive so
like in the audios he's he's a jerk and
he's quick to snap and belittle and
whatever very much like he is here but
here he does it while being oh like what
why don't you do this
listen to me like he's he's loud and
forceful on top of everything else and
he's much more subdued while maintaining
the same sort of personality general
elements and it works much better
they're here he's a bit more shouty his
sarcasm is harsher there's no there's no
there's no kindness behind it so like
when he's talking with Perry I do find
myself going why why why are they
together why why is she tribal is she
putting up with him why does he keep her
around if he seems to hate having her
around so much
there's no affection underlying the jabs
and honestly I feel like I and maybe
she's better in other episodes but in
this one particularly I feel like
Perry's putting in a pretty strong case
for being the most useless companion in
Doctor Who that's not the same as worst
companion or most aggravating or painful
to be around I think Mel still takes the
cake for that at least from what I've
seen but Perry is not helpful at all
partly inherently and partly the doctor
doesn't let her be helpful because the
instance she tries to say anything he
cuts her off and shushes her um or if
she says something helpful he goes yes I
already figured that out so like she
never contributes anything and even if
she might he stops her from doing so and
the few times she takes her own
initiative it never works
she gets captured because of it or you
know she's constantly having to be
rescued out of these situations that
she's in because she didn't listen to
the doctor or just common sense in the
first place there is at no point where
she does anything that is actively
helpful or that she doesn't have to then
be rescued out of a situation for having
done it's it's just really irritating
thankfully she's not as shrieky as
somebody like Mel she doesn't
excessively scream but she's just not
helpful she's not painful as a
personality she's just kind of useless
so the plot on this one is the doctor
and parry getting diverted and they
don't know by whom or why and they kind
of end up in in England right on the
cusp of the Industrial Revolution so and
they and they sort of end up it at
what's basically a meeting of a whole
bunch of brain trust so you've got
George Stephenson you've got Faraday
you've got a bunch of other names that
are real-life inventors you know people
who push the Industrial Revolution
forward
whose names I don't remember right now
and in the same space there is operating
the master who is the reason the doctors
TARDIS diverted he basically brought
them there but also the rogue Time Lord
scientist known as the Ronnie
so the Ronnie's deal is that she is very
focused on her experiments and her
scientific pursuits to the complete and
utter just ignoring of all other
consequences if it gets her results she
doesn't care she doesn't deal in moral
quandary so you know from from Jurassic
Park
if he and Malcolm were to ask her you
know your your scientists were so busy
thinking about whether or not
they could they didn't stop to think if
they should she never stops the thing if
she should the only thing that she
considers a well known and she should do
something is whether or not it will get
her a decent result and whether or not
it will bring the attention of anyone
who's going to try and stop her
so I on paper I like this kind of
villain I like villains who have very
who aren't don't fall
strictly speaking and the normal here's
the good guy here's the bad guy line and
that's not to say like she's an antihero
but she again on paper is what I would
classify is a wild-card villain and by
that I mean like they've got their own
agenda and their and what they're doing
is just as likely to throw off the
villains as it is to throw off the
heroes I love a good wildcard villain
Loki in Marvel often in the comics and
also to some extent in the in some of
the movies serves as a wild-card villain
but she doesn't really deliver on that
premise she honestly it feels very much
like they're trying to set her up either
as a partner with or replacement for the
master who of course is also on hand now
the this is Anthony Ainley and I've said
in the past that I can't take the
Anthony Ainley master very seriously and
part of that is just the kam penis of
his performance part of that is just
where the character was writing wise at
that point because he had been defeated
so many times it suffers from the same
problem as basically every villain from
a long-running cartoon you can't be
scared of them because they lose every
time
and after enough losses you just you
can't be intimidated and the master was
really suffering from that at this at
this point in time and I think that's
probably part of the reason the Rani was
brought on now her dynamic with the
master is antagonistic which I would
expect
and kind of works except that like they
seem to be using her to try and bolster
the master in terms of like she has
resources that he can now use because
they kind of team up but like I'm really
happy about it but at the same time
she's constantly undercutting him like
she has no she thinks nothing of his
intelligence and even less of his
ambitions and she calls him a [ __ ] and
she's got better resources than he does
blatantly and it seems like in many ways
that they're sort of using her to point
out that the master doesn't really work
anymore at the same time in which the
master is driving a fair amount of the
plot and is still trying to function as
a villain within this same story so what
she's up to in this is she's removing a
chemical from the brain of workers and a
mind and is turning them into incredibly
aggressive dangerous people now that's
not her intent it's an offshoot but it's
what happens when she removes this
chemical from their brains and it just
comes back to the fact that she doesn't
care what happens when she has what she
wants so again I I like that as an
approach for a villain but it never
really kind of goes anywhere and it also
means that what the doctor is actually
being threatened by more from the knot
is just three human mining workers I
mean they you know I'm not saying that
human beings can't be dangerous even to
the doctor but given the sort of stuff
that the doctors usually having to
contend with you know aliens explosions
you know time-travel spaceships Daleks
you know three guys with a shovel it's
it's a little bit hard to take that as
seriously you know as far as threats go
so that doesn't help things especially
and honestly I
I should have checked how long the show
have been doing the the format for this
time period which was 240 minute
episodes as a postive like your
standards for 20 22 minute episodes
because it really feels like in a lot of
way that this was written to be four
parts instead of two because like
halfway through each episode you can see
the setup to what probably would have
been a cliffhanger if they were still
doing this in four parts rather than two
so I think this was fairly early into
their decision to do that and it kind of
shows they haven't really come to grips
with this shift in format yet the
setting looks pretty good which is
actually not surprising Doctor Who
episode set in historical usually look
better because they didn't have to build
sets and they could use either
real-world locations or just stuff that
the BBC had sitting around from period
dramas so it looks decent enough feels a
little sparsely populated because it's
basically just like these couple of guys
and then you know the the other named
characters there there's no general
populace or at least it doesn't feel
like there is but overall like as much
as I'm kind of nitpicked my way through
this it's not bad it is a little bit
silly at points the the Rani has a
minefield but the mines don't explode
they turn people into trees yeah I don't
know either like that that's one of the
weirder goofier things that it's got
going on but there isn't a ton of that
there isn't a ton of like painful what
god what am I even watching stuff like
man when I was watching the two doctors
haha
so like nothing hurt but there's nothing
really particularly good about it either
it's just kind of there it gets the job
done and there isn't much more to say
about it I will say it raises my opinion
of the Rani slightly but even this I
feel like is a complete under
utilization of the concept of her I like
the concept of the Rani a heck of a lot
more than I like the execution here and
especially in her second appearance so I
feel like that there's a good concept
behind how she would function as a
villain that just was not properly mind
so it's it's kind of a shame because it
was a good enough idea the mark of the
Rani what do you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about a whole
bunch of stuff to do link to the page on
mentioned it already P o box other links
other stuff I do things and stuff and
check it out or don't that's okay too
because at the end of the day you're the
council I'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]